here's gay Pete our transportation
secretary who was completely unqualified
for the job except that he happened to
be married to a man that seems like you
might know more about Rhodes why uh
here's gay Pete talking about how
roadway fatalities are uh racist
we've got a crisis when it comes to
roadway fatalities in America we lose
about 40
000 people every year it's a level
that's comparable to gun violence and we
see a lot of racial disparities black
and brown Americans tribal citizens and
Rural residents much more likely to lose
their lives whether it's in a car or as
a pedestrian being hit by a car there
are a lot of reasons related to
discrimination related to the even the
ways that roads are designed and built
who has access to a safe Street design
that's got crosswalks and good lighting
who doesn't have that access that can
drive disparities and we have a
responsibility to act on that first off
what the hell is happening to Al
Sharpton his head is shrinking like in
Beetlejuice at the end what is going on
there you know I know he used to be big
and fat but something about the
shrinkage of his whole body strong but
now the head is fine uh Pete yes our
roads are racist there is a disparity in
the amount of black people and tribal
citizens that's a new one tribal
citizens who are getting hit by cars or
something you know also there are
cultural reasons that people behave
differently there it might be I'm just
tossing this out there because they
Whittle everything down to racism in
like oh there must be a white guy trying
to plow down a whole bunch of black
people in a car and that somehow you
know is the thing that we should be
focusing on you know culture is all act
differently some people wear seat belts
it's taught more in certain communities
I'm not even saying that specifically
with all this but like every they just
Whittle everything down to the dumbest
possible lowest common denominator that
it is racist and really in essence what
he's saying is he wants equity and debt
and what that really means is you if you
think this guy can fix anything you're a
fool and mean Pete bootage has never
accomplished anything other than using
his Democrat privilege failing at things
and moving all the way up that's what
he's really good at okay uh but if you
think they can fix anything they can't
and not only that equity and death when
so when he's saying well black and brown
brown people and what was it tribal
citizens uh they are affected by this
more what he really means is we need
more white people to die because if then
we had at least we had the equity of
death or at least more white people were
being hit by cars or wearing less seat
belts then apparently he would be happy
I know that sounds a little nuts but
that really is the truth if he got a
report
think about it when he gets these
reports and he looks at these reports
and they say well you know it does turn
out that more black and brown people
were hit by cars this month his initial
thing is oh the roads are racist right
but if he got a report and the report
said you know you're not going to
believe this gay Pete but it turns out
that we got 33 black and brown people
killed by hit by cars 33 tribal citizens
and 33 percent uh white people well I
guess by his own logic he'd be like all
right that's pretty good you guys want
to go on vacation
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]